OK. So Brown v. Board of Education, huge Supreme Court case, 1954, desegregates public schools in America, and Brown is Oliver L. Brown, a welder for the railroads and assistant pastor. It was actually 13 parents who brought the lawsuit, but he's the only one whose name is on it, not because he's first alphabetically.
好的。布朗诉教育委员会案，这可是美国最高法院的一起重大案件，发生于1954年，裁定美国公立学校废除种族隔离。布朗指的是奥利弗·L·布朗，他是一位铁路焊接工兼助理牧师。实际上，这起诉讼是由13位家长共同发起的，但只有他的名字在诉讼案上，这并非因为他在字母顺序中排在第一位。
People think maybe the lawyers picked him because he's the only dad on the list. All the other parents are moms. 1973, Roe v. Wade. Roe is Jane Roe, real name Norma McCorvey, working as a carnival barker, gets pregnant. She's already had two babies, girls, who other people were raising. She didn't want to go through that a third time.
人们猜测，律师们选择他可能是因为他是名单上唯一的父亲。其他所有家长都是母亲。1973年，罗诉韦德案。罗是指简·罗，真名是诺玛·麦考维，她当时是一名嘉年华招揽员，意外怀孕。她之前已经生了两个女儿，但由别人抚养。她不想第三次经历这一切。
At a bar one night, someone tells her that there's this thing called an abortion. Norma tries to get one, but can't-- it's illegal-- and finally signs up as the plaintiff for the lawsuit, she says, because it's the only way she can find to get the abortion she wants.
一天晚上在酒吧里，有人告诉她有“堕胎”这种事。诺玛试图去做堕胎手术，但没能成功——因为那是违法的——最终，她作为原告签署了诉讼协议，她说这是她能找到获得堕胎机会的唯一途径。
This year, the Dobbs decision that overturned Roe v. Wade, the plaintiff is an abortion clinic in Jackson, Mississippi, the Jackson Women's Health Organization. And on the day the clinic lost and Roe was overturned, that's where we wanted to be, with the people whose case was making history on the day history was made.
今年，推翻了罗诉韦德案的“多布斯裁决”，其原告是密西西比州杰克逊市的一家堕胎诊所，即杰克逊妇女健康组织。在诊所败诉、罗诉韦德案被推翻的那天，我们想要待在那里，与那些在历史性时刻亲历案件的人们在一起。
For over a decade, the clinic has been the only abortion clinic in Mississippi. Many of their clients drive from hours away. Small building, mint green roof, unmissable, super bright pink exterior, like the building is saying, yeah, we're here, deal with it.
十多年来，这家诊所一直是密西西比州唯一的堕胎诊所。许多客户甚至要开车行驶数小时才能到达这里。这是一栋小建筑，有着薄荷绿色的屋顶，外观是极其鲜艳的粉红色，让人无法忽视，仿佛建筑本身就在说：“没错，我们就在这儿，有本事来处理吧。”
Recently, they haven't allowed press inside to record, but we teamed up with a filmmaker, Maisie Crow, who filmed in the clinic starting in 2012 for a great and very nuanced movie that she made about abortion in Mississippi, and is back there now shooting another film. She was the only journalist who was allowed to be there that day, and she brought us along to witness and record these moments that no one else has seen or reported on until now.
最近，他们不再允许媒体进入拍摄。但我们与电影制作人梅西·克劳合作，她从2012年开始在诊所内拍摄，制作了一部关于密西西比州堕胎问题的精彩且极具深度的电影，现在她又回到那里拍摄另一部作品。她是那天唯一获准进入的记者，她带我们去见证并记录下这些至今无人看见或报道过的时刻。
What we've made up all this, and what we have for you today, is a special episode of our show. It is This American Life, by the way, from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass, and what we're going to do is we're going to start at the Mississippi clinic. That's basically the crash site for this massive cultural, political boulder that just landed in all of our lives with this Supreme Court decision.
我们所整理的这一切，以及今天呈现给你们的内容，是我们节目的一期特别节目。顺便说一下，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，我们要从密西西比诊所开始。这里基本上就是那块巨大的文化和政治巨石的“坠毁现场”，它随着最高法院的判决，刚刚砸进了我们所有人的生活中。
And then, after that, we're going to head out from the clinic, move up into Illinois, and then further out to Missouri and Texas, places and people who were hit by the shockwave of that impact in various ways. Stay with us.
在那之后，我们将离开诊所，前往伊利诺伊州，进而深入密苏里州和德克萨斯州，去探访那些以各种方式受到这次冲击波影响的地方和人们。请继续收听。
I'm Maisie Crow. This is Act One, The Pink House at the Center of the World. The people who work in the Pink House at the corner of Fondren and State Street have known for a while history was coming for them. They just didn't know the exact date or what they'd do in the clinic on the day it happened. Would they immediately have to cancel patients? What would they say to people? Where would they go?
我是梅西·克劳。这是第一幕，《世界中心的粉红小屋》。在丰德伦路和州街拐角处的粉红小屋工作的人们，早就预感到历史的重锤终将落下。只是他们不知道具体的日期，也不知道那一天在诊所里会发生什么。他们是否需要立即取消预约？他们该对患者说什么？他们该何去何从？
We begin this story a couple of days before the Supreme Court decision on a Wednesday night. Because their days are so busy and full, this was the first time they sat down to really discuss what to do as a group if Roe were overturned. The director of the clinic, Shannon Brewer, gathered her staff in the waiting room at the end of the workday after patients had gone home.
我们从最高法院判决前几天的一个周三晚上开始讲起。因为他们的日子太忙碌充实了，这是他们第一次坐下来，集体认真讨论如果罗诉韦德案被推翻该怎么办。诊所主任香农·布鲁尔在工作日结束、患者回家后，将全体员工召集在候诊室。
This kind of meeting with everybody together, they're not all that common at the clinic. Everybody's just too busy. So it felt serious.
像这样全员到齐的会议，在诊所并不常见。大家都太忙了，所以气氛显得格外凝重。
Y'all going to need to know what's gonna be probably going on within the next week. The decision come now either Thursday, Friday, or Monday. I think they're not going to do it till Monday, but I could be wrong. I don't know.
你们大家需要知道接下来一周可能会发生什么。裁决可能在周四、周五或周一公布。我觉得他们可能要等到周一才公布，但我也不敢肯定。我不知道。
Shannon has worked at the Jackson clinic for more than two decades. She started out at the bottom, a scrub tech sterilizing instruments. She needed a job. She had six kids, all little, and she came to the field kind of randomly. Her aunt worked at the clinic and brought her in. Shannon was 29 back then. Now she's 50 and the leader.
香农在杰克逊诊所工作了二十多年。她从底层做起，是一名负责器械消毒的洗刷技术员。当时她需要一份工作，还要抚养六个年幼的孩子，她是偶然进入这一行的，是她姨妈在诊所工作带她进来的。那时香农29岁，现在她50岁了，是那里的负责人。
We already know this, that it's going to be crazy. We're gonna-- I got to talk to-- we're having a meeting with the attorneys tomorrow, as far as what is to be done once the decision comes down, because it's been conflicting things that's been said as far as what the next step is.
我们已经知道了，接下来的情况会很疯狂。我得去——我们明天要和律师开会，确定裁决公布后具体该做些什么，因为关于接下来的步骤，之前的说法一直存在矛盾。
There's just a small staff at the clinic, very family-like, very interconnected. Shannon's sister works here. Shannon's become kind of known nationally for keeping this place open. Like, last year, she went to the White House to meet with Vice President Kamala Harris.
诊所人手很少，非常有家庭氛围，大家关系紧密。香农的妹妹也在这里工作。香农因维持诊所运转而在全国闻名。比如去年，她还去白宫见了副总统卡马拉·哈里斯。
Pretty much ever since she started, and even before she started, people have been trying to shut the Pink House down. They've tried everything. The state has buried them in regulations, wrestled them in David-and-Goliath-sized court cases. No matter what was thrown at the Pink House-- and that's what everybody calls it-- it was unshuttable. It would not stop, just like Shannon Brewer.
几乎从她开始工作，甚至在她工作之前，就一直有人试图关闭这间粉红小屋。他们用尽了一切手段。政府试图用各种法规将他们淹没，在规模巨大的诉讼案件中与他们缠斗。无论粉红小屋——这是大家对它的称呼——遭遇了什么，它始终无法被关停。它不会停止，就像香农·布鲁尔一样。
OK, one group there, one group there, six surgicals. Six surgicals. Mm.
好的，一组在那儿，一组在那儿，六台手术。六台手术。嗯。
She's rarely fazed by anything, talks to herself while she works. I've seen her be really kind to patients while she's also explaining the harsh reality that they're too far along to get an abortion in Mississippi and that they'll have to go to another state.
她很少被任何事情难倒，工作时会自言自语。我见过她对患者非常体贴，同时也向她们解释残酷的现实：她们的孕期太长了，无法在密西西比州堕胎，必须去其他州。
Her office is set up for warm, fuzzy vibes, inspirational sayings up everywhere, things like "Sometimes life's about risking it all for a dream nobody can see but you." There's also a big video monitor with feeds from the security cameras all over the building. I've never been in her office when her eyes aren't darting to the screen every few seconds.
她的办公室布置得充满温暖、温馨的氛围，到处都是励志语录，比如“有时候生活就是为了一个只有你能看到的梦想而去冒险”。还有一个大视频监控器，显示着全楼安全摄像头的画面。只要我待在她的办公室，就从没见过她的眼睛不每隔几秒就瞥向屏幕。
And what about the sign on your desk?
那办公桌上的牌子是怎么回事？
Oh, don't play with me. That's just the truth. I'm a fucking professional. What are you talking about? That is what it says.
哦，别拿我开玩笑了。那只是实话实说。我是个该死的专业人士。你在说什么？牌子上就是这么写的。
What I love about that is that it faces inward.
我喜欢它的一点是它是向内摆放的。
That's my producer, Miki.
那是我的制作人，米奇。
I know. I don't want everybody to see it because I don't want to be just-- oh my god, it's a little too ghetto. But yeah, I like it so much. I'm a fucking professional.
我知道。我不想让所有人都看见它，因为我不想显得……哦天哪，这有点太粗俗了。但确实，我太喜欢它了。我是个该死的专业人士。
How awesome would it be as, like, your press conference that you give, whenever the Supreme Court decision is, you just have this right here?
如果在最高法院裁决公布时，你举行新闻发布会，把这个摆在那儿，该有多酷啊？
I may just do that. I mean, what can it hurt at that point? That's a good idea. I think I may-- yeah. When they say, well, what would you like to say, I would say some things, but I'm a fucking professional, as you can see. So I won't. But yeah, I think I may turn it around then. It'll be the time to turn it around.
我也许真会这么做。我的意思是，到那种地步还有什么好顾忌的？这是个好主意。我想我可能——是的。当他们问，“你有什么想说的吗”，我确实有些话想说，但我毕竟是个该死的专业人士，正如你所见，所以我不会说。但是的，我想我到时候可能会把它转过来。那将是转过它的时刻。
These days, even with the entire world looking at her, Shannon was coping OK. She had this moment during the oral arguments of the Supreme Court case. She got to DC, and all she saw were anti-abortion activists and protesters and politicians everywhere cheering on the other side. Very few people showed up for her. She felt very alone.
这些天，即使全世界都在注视着她，香农也应对得还行。在最高法院案件口头辩论期间，她有过那一刻。她到了华盛顿，看到到处都是反堕胎活动人士、抗议者和欢呼雀跃的政客。很少有人支持她。她感到非常孤独。
She says she's not surprised at all by where we're at right now. So while many people are freaking out about Roe being overturned, Shannon says she's hardened to it.
她说她对我们现在的处境一点也不惊讶。所以，当许多人因为罗诉韦德案被推翻而陷入恐慌时，香农说她已经坚强起来了。
Oh, I sleep fine. I don't-- it doesn't affect my sleep. I remember years ago, when we were doing court things and had to be in and out of courts, I remember I used to have a hard time sleeping sometimes. I don't have these hard times sleeping anymore, even though this is about as real as it gets.
哦，我睡得很好。它不会影响我的睡眠。我记得几年前，当我们处理法庭事务，不得不频繁往返于法院时，我记得有时很难入睡。现在我不再有这些失眠的苦恼了，尽管这已经是最真实的现实了。
I had to come to the realization that, however this goes, I did my part. And if I know I did my part, my conscience is fine. My-- you know, everything. I can sleep well because I fought all the way into the end, regardless of who was fighting beside me. I did my part.
我得明白一个道理，无论结果如何，我尽了我的本分。如果我知道我尽力了，我的良心就没问题。你知道，一切都是。我可以睡得很香，因为我战斗到了最后，不管谁在身边支持我。我完成了我的使命。
I'm like, I did exactly what I said I would do. I stayed here. I told the women I would fight for them. I fought for them. So I sleep well, actually. Yeah.
我就像是，我确实做了我承诺过要做的事。我留在了这里。我告诉那些女性我会为她们而战。我为她们战斗了。所以，我实际上睡得很香。是的。
So just logistics-wise, all the patients that have appointments, we'll just call them all and cancel them, because there's-- I looked--
那么，从后勤角度看，所有预约过的患者，我们只需给她们打电话取消，因为——我看过了——
In that staff meeting they had two days before the Roe decision, people were nervous, asking questions about what would happen once it came down.
在罗诉韦德案判决前两天的员工会议上，大家都很紧张，询问判决公布后会发生什么。
So all those ones that have appointments, maybe those could be transferred somewhere else.
所以所有那些预约过的人，也许可以把她们转到其他地方。
Yeah, I mean, we're going to have to figure out-- I don't even know where they will be transferred at this point with the fact that many of them are coming here because other places are--
是的，我的意思是，我们得搞清楚——此时此刻我甚至不知道她们能转到哪儿去，因为她们中许多人之所以来这里，是因为其他地方已经——
Closed down.
关门了。
Are we allowed to transfer them?
我们被允许转介她们吗？
Refer? To refer?
转介？是指转介吗？
Yeah. To refer them.
是的。转介她们。
Um, I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。
OK.
好吧。
Yeah.
是的。
Shannon didn't know because no one knew. What she did know, what they all knew, was that the decision coming down would mean the end of their jobs at the Pink House and the end of the Pink House itself. Most importantly, it meant that all the patients who needed them would be stranded. The next closest clinic is three states away in Illinois.
香农不知道，因为没人知道。她所知道的是，他们所有人都知道的是，判决一下，就意味着他们在粉红小屋的工作结束了，粉红小屋本身也完了。最重要的是，这意味着所有需要他们的患者将被抛弃。最近的下一家诊所在三个州之外的伊利诺伊州。
After most of the questions petered out, the youngest member of the staff, Molly, asked a question. She hadn't talked yet, but she'd been sitting in a chair across from Shannon, nodding along as she spoke, hyper concentrating on Shannon's face as she tried to absorb it all.
在大部分问题讨论完后，最年轻的员工莫莉提出了一个问题。她之前没说过话，但一直坐在香农对面，随着香农说话而点头，全神贯注地看着香农的脸，试图消化这一切。
I've got a question.
我有个问题。
Uh-huh?
嗯？
How do you feel?
你感觉怎么样？
About what?
关于什么？
Everything.
一切。
This is overwhelming, really. It's really just overwhelming. I've been so focused on the next step, the next step because that's how my mind works. It's like it's just not focusing on what is wrong but rather what is the next step, because that's the only way I can keep going to where I didn't really think about the emotional part of it.
这真的让人不知所措，真的。我太专注于下一步、再下一步了，因为我的大脑就是这样运作的。它不去关注哪里错了，而是关注下一步该做什么，因为这是我能继续前行的唯一方式，所以我没怎么去想情感上的部分。
Right.
没错。
Until when the doctor started saying-- Dr. Hamlin first, on her last day, she was like-- she came to me, and it was kind of sad. She was like, well, I don't know if I'm going to see y'all again here.
直到那位医生开始说——哈姆林医生在最后一天，她当时……她来找我，心情很低落。她说，好吧，我不知道以后还能不能在这里见到你们了。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
I was like, what do you mean? It's because it just did not register with me. That's when it really started registering with me, because, before then, it honestly wasn't. Like I was telling her today, it probably won't really hit me until the last day that I walk out of here. I've been here 21 years.
我就说，你什么意思？因为我当时根本没意识到。也就是那时我才真正开始有实感，因为在那之前，真的没有。就像我今天跟她说的，可能直到我走出这里的最后一天，它才会真正冲击到我。我在这里工作了21年了。
Wow.
哇。
You know?
你知道吗？
That's a long time.
那是很长的时间。
It's like, wow.
就像是，哇。
It's your baby.
这是你的心血。
So yeah, it's pretty sad, actually.
所以是的，这真的很令人伤心。
Yeah, it's really sad.
是的，真的很伤心。
The staff, who, in good times is, chatty, laughy, was oddly quiet in the room, everyone just looking at Shannon. All these other clinics around the country under the same threat were already shutting their doors. Even though the decision hadn't come down yet, they had decided it was over. South Dakota, Oklahoma, those clinics were planning the end. But Shannon was expanding.
员工们在平时很健谈、爱笑，但房间里却异样地安静，每个人都看着香农。全国所有面临同样威胁的其他诊所都已经关门了。尽管裁决还没下来，他们就已经决定一切结束了。南达科他州、俄克拉荷马州，那些诊所都在筹划关门事宜。但香农在扩张。
Shannon had decided that if the state was going to close the Pink House in Jackson, Mississippi, she was going to help open a new Pink House west in New Mexico. It was within driving distance of Mississippi, a long drive, 15 hours, but still, she hoped she could open the doors in that clinic the day the doors in this one closed. At this meeting, she told her staff, I'm going out to get the new clinic ready. You stay here and keep going.
香农决定，如果政府要关掉密西西比州杰克逊的粉红小屋，她就要去新墨西哥州帮忙开设一家新的粉红小屋。它距离密西西比州还在车程范围内，虽然要开15个小时，但她希望这家诊所能在原先这家诊所关闭的当天就开门。在这次会议上，她告诉员工：“我要去准备新诊所了。你们留在这里，继续坚持下去。”
I'm gonna be leaving. I'm gonna be gone in the morning. So I'm not going to be here tomorrow. So I was going to tell y'all just before I go.
我要走了。明天早上我就走。所以我明天不在。所以我打算在走之前告诉你们。
Keep going until the last possible moment of the last possible day. That's what they'd been doing for almost 30 years. That's what they'd keep doing.
坚持到最后一天、最后一刻。这就是他们近30年来一直在做的事。这也是他们会继续做的事。
That's all. Y'all got any other questions?
就这样。你们还有其他问题吗？
So tomorrow as usual unless we hear something?
那明天照常上班，除非我们听到什么消息？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, everything is as usual. Unless I'm calling saying, do this, don't do this anymore, blah, blah, blah, you just do what you normally do.
是的，是的，是的，一切照旧。除非我打电话说“做这个，别再做那个了”，诸如此类，你们就按平常做就行。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. I just wanted to tell y'all that so that everybody have a better understanding. Yep, yep.
是的。我只是想告诉你们，这样每个人都能有更好的了解。没错，没错。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're welcome, baby. You're welcome. You're welcome. You're welcome. All right, let's see. Oh, my goodness.
不客气，宝贝。不客气。不客气。不客气。好的，来看看。哦，我的天哪。
The staff left. Shannon walked back to her office and just sat there.
员工们离开了。香农回到办公室，就那样坐着。
Oh, lordy, lordy, lordy.
哦，天哪，天哪，天哪。
I've known Shannon for years, spent hundreds of hours with her. She rarely cracks. She doesn't often show emotion.
我认识香农多年，和她相处了数百个小时。她很少崩溃。她不常表现出情绪。
How did that feel?
感觉如何？
The talking was fine. I was watching their faces. Watching their faces was not as easy. It's like you could see it.
谈话本身还好。我在观察他们的表情。观察他们的表情就没那么容易了。就像你能看到它。
I watched as wave after wave of realization hit Shannon in real time.
我目睹了一波又一波的现实实时冲击着香农。
[SIGHS] Mm, girl. This world we live in. It's just amazing what they let people do to certain people, to poor people, to Black people, to people that already been suffering and going through so much all they life. And it's like it's just never ending sometimes. You know what I'm saying?
[叹气] 哎，女孩。我们生活的这个世界。他们竟然允许对某些人、对穷人、对黑人、对那些一生都在受苦、经历过太多折磨的人做出这种事，真是太不可思议了。有时感觉这一切永远不会结束。你知道我的意思吗？
Every-- people who do it. That's the thing. These are the same people who elect-- the ones who elect these people to do this. These are our neighbors and [SIGHS] our preachers and our people that are just around us all the time.
那些做这件事的人。问题就在这儿。正是这些人选举了——选举出这些人来做这些事。他们是我们的邻居，[叹气] 我们的牧师，我们身边的人，一直都在我们周围。
These are the ones who are electing these people, putting these people in these positions to take stuff from us. Ah. As if we haven't had enough stuff taken from us all these years. That's crazy. [SIGHS] I don't want to talk about this no more. I got to go outside.
就是这些人选举了他们，把他们推上这些位置来剥夺我们的东西。啊。就好像这些年来我们被剥夺的东西还不够多似的。这太疯狂了。[叹气] 我不想再谈这个了。我得出去走走。
Two days later, outside the clinic, Friday, what ended up being the day the Supreme Court handed down the decision. It started off like a normal day. Protesters lined the street, screaming at staff, screaming at patients. The protesters today are the same as usual, mostly all men, mostly all white.
两天后，诊所外，周五，最终成了最高法院公布判决的那一天。这一天开始得像平常一样。抗议者站在街边，对员工大喊大叫，对患者大喊大叫。今天的抗议者和往常一样，几乎全是男性，几乎全是白人。
A man gets up on a ladder with a bullhorn, leans down over the pink stucco wall of the clinic, shouting Bible verses about damnation. The people who manage this scene are called the Pink House defenders. Their job is to guide patients safely inside the clinic and shield them from the protesters.
一个男人踩着梯子，拿着扩音器，俯身在诊所的粉色灰泥墙上，大声宣读关于诅咒的圣经经文。管理这些现场的人被称为“粉红小屋捍卫者”。他们的工作是引导患者安全进入诊所，并将她们与抗议者隔离开。
The protesters scream murderer at patients, and the defenders blast music on speakers to drown them out. They don't want the patients to have to hear all the yelling. Their playlist, inexplicably '90s alt rock, Smashing Pumpkins, Toad the Wet Sprocket. Today, it's Tom Petty.
抗议者对患者高喊“杀人犯”，捍卫者则用音箱播放音乐来盖过他们的声音。他们不想让患者听到这些叫喊声。他们的播放列表莫名其妙全是90年代的另类摇滚，南瓜乐团，蟾蜍潮湿链轮。今天放的是汤姆·佩蒂。
[MUSIC - TOM PETTY, "I WON'T BACK DOWN"]
[音乐 - 汤姆·佩蒂，《我不会退缩》]
Jesus Christ died for sinners once for all, the righteous and unrighteous, to bring us to God!
耶稣基督为罪人死了一次，为了义人和不义的人，把我们带向了上帝！
The defenders are led by Derenda Hancock. She's 63, a wiry blonde, who managed restaurants for decades and now waits tables at a chain steakhouse. She'll as quickly yell go fuck yourself to a protester as she'll whisper, right this way, baby girl, to a patient.
捍卫者由德伦达·汉考克领导。她63岁，身材干瘦的白人女性，做了几十年的餐厅经理，现在在一家连锁牛排馆当服务员。她对抗议者会咆哮“去你的”，也会轻声对患者说“这边走，小姑娘”。
For 10 years, she's posted herself outside in front of the Pink House, not for money. All the defenders do it for free. Derenda's been here since 4:45 AM. Her usual is 6:45, but the protesters have been starting early this week, and she does not like them to get here before her, ever.
十年来，她每天都站在粉红小屋前，不是为了钱。所有捍卫者都是免费志愿服务的。德伦达凌晨4:45就到了。她平时是6:45到，但本周抗议者来得越来越早，她绝不喜欢他们比她先到。
But we'll get you in as soon as you're ready, honey, OK?
没事的，等你准备好了我们就带你进去，亲爱的，好吗？
Just after 9:00, the news from the Supreme Court comes down. Derenda speed walks into the clinic.
9点刚过，最高法院的消息传来。德伦达快步走进诊所。
I need to go check on the staff. I'm going to check on the staff.
我得去看看员工们。我去看看员工们。
--shall turn from their wicked ways and pray, seek my fate. Then I will hear from heaven [INAUDIBLE]. This nation [INAUDIBLE].
——当转离他们的邪恶道路并祈祷，寻求我的命运。然后我会从天庭垂听[听不清]。这个国家[听不清]。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Do we have any direction? It's over.
我们有什么指示吗？结束了。
Oh, it's over?
哦，结束了？
It's over.
结束了。
They go past the reception desk, down the hallway, a small cluster of staff keeping their voices low so they don't alarm the patients.
他们走过接待台，穿过走廊，一小群员工压低声音，以免惊动患者。
I messaged Shannon. I'm waiting to hear back what we're supposed to do. I mean, we're not-- this is fine, but, yeah, it went down.
我给香农发了信息。我在等回复我们该做什么。我的意思是，我们不——这还好，但确实，判决下来了。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
They hug.
他们拥抱在一起。
I can't break.
我不能崩溃。
Don't break. Stay strong, baby. Stay strong.
别崩溃。保持坚强，宝贝。保持坚强。
Oh, Miss Derenda, It's OK. It's OK.
哦，德伦达女士，没事的。没事的。
I know.
我知道。
It's OK.
没事的。
We're going to be all right.
我们会没事的。
It's OK.
没事的。
I know. I can't cry out there.
我知道。我不能在外面哭。
OK.
好的。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Thank you. I can't be out there like that. There's so much press.
谢谢。我不能在外面那样。媒体太多了。
Don't let them see you like that.
别让他们看到你那个样子。
Don't let them see you like that, someone tells Derenda.
别让他们看到你那个样子，有人对德伦达说。
You know I won't.
你知道我不会的。
This is the entire conversation. They give themselves precisely 49 seconds for all of it. Then Derenda heads for the door. She has to get her team together to deal with the crowd of protesters and press.
这就是全部对话。他们一共只给了自己49秒。然后德伦达走向门口。她必须召集她的团队来应对门外的抗议者和媒体。
Strong Derenda.
坚强的德伦达。
Strong Derenda, someone yells behind her. As the door closes, she turns around and shouts back.
坚强的德伦达，有人在她身后大喊。门关上时，她转过身喊道。
Not stronger than you. [LAUGHS]
没你们强。[笑]
You gotta lay down your shame!
你们得放下你们的耻辱！
I need everybody. I need everybody. I need all my people!
我需要所有人。我需要所有人。我需要我的人！
Protesters are trying to block the driveway to the clinic.
抗议者正试图堵住诊所的车道。
Stay out of the fucking driveway!
离车道远点，该死的！
Holiness. Holiness. Righteousness! Oh, the Lord, our righteousness!
圣洁。圣洁。正义！哦，主啊，我们的正义！
For a few seconds, as Derenda slips out the door, the noise from outside pours in. And then the doors close, shoving the world back outside for the staff to figure out what to do now.
当德伦达溜出门时，外面的噪音涌进来几秒钟。随后门关上，将世界隔绝在外，让员工们去思索接下来该做什么。
Oh, wow. Oh my god.
哦，天哪。哦，我的天哪。
The staff members collect themselves immediately and get back to answering the calls. The phones are backing up, ringing constantly, the lights blinking non-stop on all the office lines.
员工们立刻整理心情，继续回复电话。电话响个不停，办公室线路上的灯一直在闪烁。
Jackson Women's Health. May I help you? No. No, ma'am. We're not doing any more abortions. The decision came out, and it's in effect in 26 states.
杰克逊妇女健康中心。有什么可以帮您的？不。不，女士。我们不再做堕胎手术了。裁决已经下来了，在26个州生效。
Women calling, wanting abortions, wanting to know, can you still help me, can you get me in, looking for any clinic still open in the Southern half of the country.
打进来的女性想做堕胎手术，想知道你们还能不能帮我，能不能让我进去，寻找南部地区唯一还在营业的诊所。
Jackson Women's Health. Ma'am, we cannot reschedule your appointment.
杰克逊妇女健康中心。女士，我们不能重新安排您的预约。
Any staff member who can is grabbing calls.
任何能接听的员工都在接电话。
Jackson Women's Health, hold please. Jackson Women's Health, hold please.
杰克逊妇女健康中心，请稍候。杰克逊妇女健康中心，请稍候。
Jackson Women's Health. May I help you? OK, we're not accepting new appointments. We are closing. I don't know if you saw the news. We are-- they have overturned us. And that's crazy, ain't it? How they gonna tell somebody what to do with their body? Yes, ma'am. It hurts my soul. Yes, ma'am. Call back in [INAUDIBLE].
杰克逊妇女健康中心。有什么可以帮您的？好的，我们不接受新预约了。我们要关闭了。我不知道您看新闻了吗。我们被——他们推翻了我们的权利。这很疯狂，不是吗？他们怎么能告诉别人该怎么对待自己的身体？是的，女士。这伤害了我的灵魂。是的，女士。请[听不清]后再打。
All day, people are asking, so if I can't get an abortion in Mississippi, what should I do?
整整一天，人们都在问，如果我在密西西比州没法堕胎，我该怎么办？
Jackson Women's Health, may I help you?
杰克逊妇女健康中心，有什么可以帮您的？
With Shannon in New Mexico opening Pink House West, her sister Nita takes charge.
随着香农在新墨西哥州开设粉红小屋西部，她的妹妹妮塔担负起了重任。
Jackson Women's Health, may I help you?
杰克逊妇女健康中心，有什么可以帮您的？
Like everyone else, Nita's answering the phones.
像其他人一样，妮塔在接电话。
No, that's going to be a hard decision. It's kind of hard right now to think that it will reopen back up, but I don't think it will reopen back up, sweetheart. I'm so sorry. It's sad. It's really sad. It's tearing my heart up. Trust me, because people don't know what other people go through, you know what I'm saying? And it really hurts. I know, sweetheart.
不，那将是一个艰难的决定。现在要认为它还会重新开放太难了，但我认为它不会再开放了，亲爱的。我很抱歉。这很令人伤心。真的很伤心。它让我的心碎了。相信我，因为人们不知道别人经历了什么，你知道我的意思吗？这真的很疼。我知道，亲爱的。
People ask, if there's no more abortion, what am I supposed to do? One caller asked, can I get my tubes tied?
人们问，如果没有堕胎了，我该怎么办？一位来电者问，我可以结扎输卵管吗？
Uh-huh. You want your tubes tied. I don't know, sweetheart. You have to call the hospital and see do they tie tubes at certain-- you said you have three kids. Now, back in the days, they did that. When you had three kids, they would tie your tubes, but that was in Chicago.
嗯。你想结扎输卵管。我不知道，亲爱的。你得打给医院看他们是否在特定情况下做结扎手术——你说你有三个孩子。以前，他们做过。当你生了三个孩子，他们会给你结扎，但那是芝加哥的做法。
We don't do that here at the abortion clinic. We don't do that here, but you have to call the hospital for that, sweetheart. OK. No, ma'am. We don't have no more Plan Bs. You're welcome. Jackson Women's Health. OK. [SIGHS] [INAUDIBLE]
我们堕胎诊所不做那个。我们这里不做那个，但你得打给医院问问，亲爱的。好的。不，女士。我们也没有事后紧急避孕药了。不客气。杰克逊妇女健康中心。好的。[叹气][听不清]
Get yourself together, Nita. Get yourself together. I'm gonna be OK. I'm gonna be OK. Yeah.
振作起来，妮塔。振作起来。我会没事的。我会没事的。是的。
This is the sound of Roe ending. All day long, the phones never let up.
这就是罗诉韦德案结束的声音。整整一天，电话响个不停。
Jackson Women's Health. No, ma'am, we're not taking any more new appointments right now. No, ma'am, I do not. The decision's court just came in. So we don't know, ma'am.
杰克逊妇女健康中心。不，女士，我们现在不接受任何新预约了。不，女士，我不知道。法院的裁决才刚下来。所以我们不知道，女士。
Jackson Women's Health, may I help you?
杰克逊妇女健康中心，有什么可以帮您的？
Before long, they come up with a new plan. I'll tell you more later in the hour.
不久，他们想出了一个新计划。我稍后会在节目里详细讲。
We're not doing any more, ma'am. Tennessee is closed too, ma'am. It's just one of them. You welcome. Jackson Women's Health, may I help you?
我们不做任何手术了，女士。田纳西州也关门了，女士。这是其中之一。不客气。杰克逊妇女健康中心，有什么可以帮您的？
This is Zoe Chace with Act 2. Welcome to Illinois, Abortion Oasis.
我是佐伊·查斯，为您带来第二幕。欢迎来到伊利诺伊州，堕胎绿洲。
So what we're about to do, we're going to take this call, and this is probably a person that's requesting for some assistance. By this area code, they're probably calling me from Tennessee, OK? Regional Logistics Center. This is Carolyn. How can I help you?
我们要接这个电话，这可能是一个寻求帮助的人。根据这个区号，他们可能从田纳西州打来，好吗？地区物流中心。我是卡罗琳。有什么可以帮您的？
500 miles away from Jackson, in Fairview Heights, Illinois, there's this big building, a sparkling new abortion complex, a mega clinic made for the post Roe world. Planned Parenthood decided they needed to build a place where everyone coming from all the other places could go, the Mississippis, the Texases, Oklahoma, Missouri. St. Louis is just across the river.
距离杰克逊500英里外，在伊利诺伊州的费尔维尤高地，有一栋大楼，那是一个闪亮的新堕胎综合体，是为“罗诉韦德案”后的世界而建的超级诊所。美国计划生育协会决定建立一个地方，让来自所有其他地方的人——密西西比州、德克萨斯州、俄克拉荷马州、密苏里州——都能到这里来。圣路易斯就在河对岸。
I was there a couple of weeks ago. It's 18,000 square feet, a maze of bright hallways and procedure rooms and counseling rooms and the innocuously-named, but very important, Regional Logistics Center. That's where Carolyn Sheryll works.
几周前我去了那里。它有18,000平方英尺，是一个明亮走廊、手术室、咨询室组成的迷宫，还有名字听着平淡却至关重要的“地区物流中心”。那就是卡罗琳·谢里尔工作的地方。
OK. So are you needing travel assistance and procedure funding? How many total people in your household?
好的。那么你需要旅行援助和手术资金吗？你家一共几口人？
Carolyn's job is to get people to this huge clinic for an abortion and connect them to what they need in order to do that, mostly money. She's from St. Louis. She has neon yellow nails that click loudly. She types fast.
卡罗琳的工作是让人们来到这个巨大的诊所接受堕胎，并联系她们所需的一切，主要是钱。她来自圣路易斯。她留着霓虹黄色的指甲，打字时发出响亮的点击声，速度很快。
She's got this little sign up right in her line of vision that says, "Stand with Black women," and that's why she does this job, she says, to help young women like herself. She's warm when you meet her, but on the phone, she has this impersonal customer service voice. There's a lot of forms and information she needs to get through.
她在视线正前方放了一个小牌子，写着“与黑人女性站在一起”，她说这就是她做这份工作的原因，为了帮助像她一样的年轻女性。见到她时她很热情，但在电话里，她有一种公事公办的客服腔调。有很多表格和信息她需要过一遍。
All right, and your total household monthly income? And what procedure are you choosing, the medical pill or the surgical?
好了，你家每月的总收入是多少？你选择哪种程序，药物流产还是手术？
The woman on the phone, who is from Tennessee, tells Carolyn she wants a surgical abortion.
电话那头的女性来自田纳西州，她告诉卡罗琳她想要手术流产。
The total cost of that service is $540. How much did you have towards that balance?
这项服务的总费用是540美元。你凑到了多少余额？
She says she only has $100. Carolyn's computer program can instantly tap into abortion funds from all over the country. It'll take $100 from the National Abortion Federation, $75 from the Chicago abortion fund, and automatically apply that to the patient's balance. On this call, she also tabs over and squares pop-up with the names of all the states. She clicks Tennessee to find the local abortion fund.
她说她只有100美元。卡罗琳的电脑程序可以立即调用全国各地的堕胎基金。它会从全国堕胎联合会提取100美元，从芝加哥堕胎基金提取75美元，并自动将其计入患者的余额。在这个电话中，她还点开标签，弹出了所有州的名称。她点击田纳西州以寻找当地的堕胎基金。
I am going to reach out to some funders in your state. Let's see exactly who that will be. You're coming from Tennessee, correct? All right, and what county are you located in?
我打算联系你们州的一些资助者。让我们看看具体是谁。你是从田纳西州来的，对吧？好的，你所在的县是？
Last year, Carolyn was working at Planned Parenthood as just an appointment booker. There was no Regional Logistics Center yet, no place which found financial support for travel and stuff. Carolyn's only job was scheduling the appointments, the date and time that people should show up, which was stressful.
去年，卡罗琳在计划生育协会工作时只是个负责预约的人。那时还没有地区物流中心，没有寻找旅行和开销支持的地方。卡罗琳唯一的工作就是安排预约，安排人们出现的时间和日期，这压力很大。
I used to hang up every day like, what are we going to do? How are they going to make it? What's she going to do? Like, you have those thoughts like, I wonder how she's going to make it to her appointment. I wonder where she's going to find the rest of that money that we said that she needs.
我每天挂断电话时都会想，我们该怎么办？她们怎么过得去？她会怎么办？就像，你会想，不知道她能不能准时到达预约地点。我不知道她该从哪儿凑到我们说她还差的那部分钱。
So yeah, people need support. These young women need somebody to stand up for them, give them encouragement that they are making the right decision. I mean, you don't understand the need that comes across this phone.
所以是的，人们需要支持。这些年轻女性需要有人站出来支持她们，鼓励她们，让她们相信自己做出了正确的决定。我的意思是，你无法理解这些电话背后的需求。
Like this patient who just drove down from Michigan, who was there in the waiting room just down the hall. Carolyn got an urgent message about her from the staff at the front desk.
比如刚才那位从密歇根州开车过来的患者，她就在走廊尽头的候诊室里。卡罗琳收到了前台同事关于她的紧急信息。
All right, give me one second.
好的，给我一秒钟。
The woman is 25 weeks pregnant, right on the line of what is allowed, and had just driven over 500 miles. She'd showed up with $1,500, not nearly enough for that procedure, which is about $5,000, because it's a complicated procedure at that point. It can take two to three days. So if the woman doesn't get the rest of the money like right then, her window snaps shut.
这位女性怀孕25周，正处于允许流产的临界线，刚开了500多英里。她带着1500美元来了，离手术费还差很远，因为那个手术大约要5000美元，因为在这个孕周进行手术很复杂。手术可能需要两到三天。所以如果这位女性没法立即凑齐剩下的钱，她的窗口就会关闭。
All right, so we did get you pretty much funded. Pay the 15 that you did state that you do have, and I'll worry about this $400 balance and get this covered for you, OK?
好的，我们基本上为你凑齐了资金。付你说的1500美元，我会搞定剩下的400美元余额，没问题吧？
Carolyn hangs up. We could have paid for her hotel, she's saying, shaking her head, then she'd have that extra $400.
卡罗琳挂了电话。她说，如果我们能支付她的酒店费用，她就能省下那额外的400美元。她摇了摇头。
But we'll get it. So watch. Watch me work.
但我们会搞定的。看着吧，看着我怎么工作。
I was told this new abortion complex might have to go from eight hours of patient care a day to 10 hours, and then probably 12. Already, one doctor on site sees around nine patients an hour. That's how fast an abortion can be, as little as three minutes, and it's over. They're projecting 14,000 new patients in the next year coming to Southern Illinois from nearby states.
有人告诉我，这个新的堕胎综合体可能不得不从每天8小时的诊疗时间延长到10小时，然后可能是12小时。已经在现场的一位医生每小时能接待9名患者。堕胎手术可以这么快，仅需3分钟，一切就结束了。他们预计未来一年将有14,000名新患者从邻近各州涌入伊利诺伊州南部。
Which brings me to Act 3, The Abortion Desert Across the River. On June 24, the day Roe was overturned, I was in St. Louis, Missouri. I drove to meet a Missouri State representative named Mary Elizabeth Coleman. Mary Elizabeth Coleman has been running at abortion for years. She never stops running.
这带我进入了第三幕，《河对岸的堕胎荒漠》。6月24日，罗诉韦德案被推翻的那天，我在密苏里州的圣路易斯。我开车去见一位名叫玛丽·伊丽莎白·科尔曼的密苏里州众议员。玛丽·伊丽莎白·科尔曼多年来一直致力于禁止堕胎。她从不停下脚步。
Practically, the moment she got to the statehouse, she was helping to write a heartbeat bill. That bill included the trigger ban that ended abortion in the state of Missouri. In the last few months, she's been getting a lot of attention for this strategy that she came up with to attack the mega clinic Planned Parenthood built in Illinois.
她进入州议会大厦的那一刻起，就在协助起草“心跳法案”。该法案包括了在密苏里州禁止堕胎的触发条款。过去几个月里，她因为想出的攻击计划生育协会在伊利诺伊州建立的超级诊所的策略而受到了很多关注。
Mary Elizabeth wrote a bill that would punish people who helped someone in Missouri cross state lines to get an abortion. The bill didn't go anywhere, but it's getting a lot of attention right now. Lots of people are talking about state lines as the next frontier in the fight against abortion.
玛丽·伊丽莎白写了一项法案，惩罚那些帮助密苏里州人跨州堕胎的人。该法案并没有通过，但现在受到了极大关注。许多人正在谈论州界线作为反对堕胎斗争的下一个前沿。
The day Roe fell, Mary Elizabeth told me to meet her at the Cathedral Basilica of St. Louis, closest Catholic Church, just down the street, to the last abortion clinic in Missouri.
罗诉韦德案倒下的那天，玛丽·伊丽莎白让我去圣路易斯主教座堂广场找她，那是离密苏里州最后一家堕胎诊所最近的天主教堂，就在街尽头。
Um, what are we doing here?
嗯，我们在这里做什么？
So I just was praying at the adoration chapel here and, yeah, just kind of taking a minute.
我刚才在圣体礼拜堂祈祷，是的，只是花了一分钟时间。
She's come to this church many times to pray for the end of abortion in their Adoration Chapel, the special place in the church where Catholics believe God is literally present. We were whispering just outside the doorway. This moment she'd been working her whole life for felt so heavy.
她多次来到这座教堂在圣体礼拜堂祈祷，请求堕胎结束，这是教堂中天主教徒相信上帝真正临在的特殊地方。我们在门口低声交谈。这一刻，她为之奋斗了一生，感觉如此沉重。
I just feel really, really sad about all the lives that have been lost and mourn all of the people who've been harmed and also feel just an incredible sense of gratitude and peace and joy that this has been fixed, that this terrible decision has been overcome. And it's an incredible victory for people like me, who call ourselves the pro-life generation.
我感到非常、非常悲伤，想到所有那些失去的生命，哀悼所有受到伤害的人，同时也感到一种难以置信的感激、平静和喜悦，因为这件事终于被修复了，那个可怕的判决终于被克服了。对于像我这样称自己为“捍卫生命一代”的人来说，这是一个不可思议的胜利。
Like, I was adamant that we would be-- just adamant as a kid that we'd be the generation that would end Roe, and, like, it happened, and it worked, and it just feels really overwhelming.
记得小时候，我坚信我们要成为终结罗诉韦德案的一代人，它真的发生了，而且成功了，这种感觉让人难以置信地难以承受。
Alongside these feelings, she says, is worry. She's thinking about the response, the way people are going to react to what happened, what that's going to look like, what that's going to feel like.
她说，伴随着这些感受的，还有忧虑。她正在思考人们的反应，人们会如何对待发生的事情，那会是什么样子，那会是什么感觉。
The day Roe fell also happened to be the feast day celebrating the birth of Saint John the Baptist, the guy known for preparing the way for Jesus and baptizing him in the Bible. It's traditionally celebrated with a bonfire. Mary Elizabeth and 60 of her closest friends gathered at her house that night with her parish priest.
罗诉韦德案倒下的那天恰好是庆祝施洗者约翰诞生的节日，那个人以在圣经中为耶稣预备道路并为他施洗而闻名。按照传统，这节日要用篝火庆祝。玛丽·伊丽莎白和她60位亲密朋友那天晚上在她家和教区牧师聚在一起。
Should we like the fire?
我们点火吗？
It was drinks, chips, prayer, s'mores.
大家有酒、薯片、祷告、烤棉花糖。
What a wonderful day.
多么美好的一天。
Agreed. I know. I've cried twice today.
同意。我知道。我今天哭了两次。
Have you?
你也是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You're a big crier too.
你也是个爱哭鬼。
I am.
我是。
It's not like shouts of victory here. It's more like nudging each other. Can you believe it?
这里没有胜利的欢呼，更像是大家在互相示意。“你敢相信吗？”
Is it real? Is it real? Like, am I going to wake up tomorrow going, it really is real, you know? I think I will, but right now, I'm just like, it is real. It is real. Pinch me. You know? It is real.
这是真的吗？是真的吗？明天醒来，我真的会去想，这一切是真的吗？我想我会，但现在，我就觉得这一切是真的。是真的。掐我一下。你知道吗？这是真的。
Yeah.
是的。
You can't overstate what a big day this is for pro-life Catholics. This has been a long fight for some of them. Here they were, reminiscing about how many Marches for Life they've been on.
你无法夸大这对捍卫生命的天主教徒来说是多么重要的一天。对他们中的一些人来说，这是一场漫长的战斗。他们在这里回忆着自己参加过多少次“为生命游行”。
It just makes it worthwhile, because those were brutal trips. You're on a bus all night. You get up there. You're exhausted.
这让一切都变得值得，因为那些旅程太痛苦了。你整晚都在巴士上。你到达那里。你筋疲力尽。
Thank you for coming out and for being here on this feast of John the Baptist.
感谢你们在施洗者约翰节来到这里。
Chris, Mary Elizabeth's husband, gathers everyone out back.
克里斯，玛丽·伊丽莎白的老公，把大家召集到后院。
And what a glorious day, and a beautiful evening for a fire. Father, it's all yours.
多么辉煌的一天，美丽的篝火之夜。神父，交给您了。
And I can't resist having a captive audience just to say a quick word.
我忍不住要对听众说几句话。
Saint John the Baptist's story starts with something called The Visitation. While she's pregnant, Mary goes to see her cousin Elizabeth, who's also pregnant. Upon seeing Mary, Elizabeth feels her child leap in her womb, recognizing Jesus, the Savior, in Mary's womb. Elizabeth basically says, Mary, your pregnancy is going to turn out great. Mary Elizabeth. This story from the Bible is her namesake.
施洗者约翰的故事始于所谓的“圣母访亲”。玛丽怀孕时去看望同样怀孕的表姐伊丽莎白。看到玛丽时，伊丽莎白感觉到她腹中的孩子跳动起来，认出了玛丽腹中的耶稣，救世主。伊丽莎白基本上说：“玛丽，你的怀孕会带来伟大的结果。”玛丽·伊丽莎白。这个圣经故事是她名字的由来。
Roe v. Wade is overturned, for which many people like Mary Elizabeth have striven so hard to bring about a culture of life.
罗诉韦德案被推翻了，许多像玛丽·伊丽莎白这样的人为实现生命文化而努力奋斗的目标终于实现了。
The bonfire burned out. The night went late. Mary Elizabeth told me she went to bed with this bracing feeling, holding her breath, some relief, but also dread, she said, about what happens next.
篝火熄灭了。夜深了。玛丽·伊丽莎白告诉我，她带着一种如释重负却又紧绷的感觉上床睡觉，屏住呼吸，既有解脱，也有对接下来会发生什么的恐惧。
The Lord be with you.
愿主与你们同在。
Holy spirit.
圣灵。
Let us pray. Oh, Lord, God, father almighty, unfailing ray and source of all light, sanctify this new fire, and grant that after the darkness--
让我们祈祷。哦，主啊，上帝，全能的父，不竭的光芒和一切光明的源泉，圣化这新火，并赐予我们，在那黑暗之后——
This is Act 4, Next. What happens next is a subject for so many pro-life lawmakers, who spent years, like Mary Elizabeth, hoping to get to this point and overturn Roe. I should say that throughout today's program, we're using the terms for people on each side of this issue that they choose themselves-- like pro-life.
这是第四幕，《接下来》。接下来会发生什么，是许多像玛丽·伊丽莎白一样，多年来希望达到这一点并推翻罗诉韦德案的“捍卫生命”立法者们的讨论课题。我应该说，在今天的节目中，我们使用了争议双方各自选择的术语——比如“捍卫生命”。
I've talked to a few of these lawmakers, and opinions really are all over the place. There's no consensus on how to proceed, just a general sense that the courts and Supreme Court seem to be on their side. And so there's no telling how far they're going to be able to go right now. Like, for example, here's one of the biggest questions out there that lawmakers in the movement do not agree on.
我跟一些议员谈过，他们的意见确实各不相同。关于如何进行没有共识，只是普遍感觉到法院和最高法院似乎站在他们一边。所以现在没人说得准他们能走多远。例如，这是目前立法者们无法达成共识的最大问题之一。
The question is, should states that ban abortion try to do anything about all the people who are going to cross state lines to get abortions in clinics like the one in Illinois that Zoe visited. What can they do? The Thomas More Society, this conservative nonprofit, has put together model legislation on this. They are one of a handful of outfits throwing out legal strategies right now. Peter Breen is their Vice President and senior counsel.
问题是，禁止堕胎的州是否应该对那些跨州前往像佐伊访问的那类伊利诺伊州诊所寻求堕胎的人做些什么？他们能做什么？保守派非营利组织托马斯·莫尔协会制定了示范立法。他们是目前抛出各种法律策略的少数组织之一。彼得·布林是他们的副主席兼高级顾问。
Well, if you frame the question as trying to stop someone from across a state line, your natural instinct might be, oh, well, I don't think you can do that. But when you frame the question in the way that the Dobbs Supreme Court majority framed it, which is, this is an unborn human child, well, then the question looks a lot different, and the unborn child is now a resident and can be treated as a resident of their home state.
嗯，如果你把问题定义为试图阻止某人跨越州界，你的本能可能觉得，噢，我觉得你做不到。但当你用多布斯案多数派法官那种方式去定义这个问题时——也就是这是一个未出生的孩子——那么问题看起来就完全不同了，这个未出生的孩子现在是居民，可以被视为其家乡州的居民。
And when you look at it that way, the state's interest in protecting a minor who is a resident of that state, you can't just take the minor across state lines to do something illegal to that minor. That would be a grave crime. It is something that, in other contexts, such as sex trafficking or child abuse, no one would challenge that that home state has jurisdiction to protect that child.
当你从那个角度看时，州政府保护作为该州居民的未成年人的利益，你不能仅仅为了对该未成年人做违法之事就带她跨州。那将是严重的犯罪。在性交易或虐待儿童等其他情况下，没人会质疑家乡州有权保护该儿童。
Would the courts agree with him? That is totally unclear. It raises complicated legal questions, and other pro-life legislators and legal thinkers do not think this is a slam dunk at all. But strategists are floating all sorts of ideas like this right now, and nobody knows which of those laws are going to hold up in court.
法院会同意他的观点吗？那完全不清楚。这引发了复杂的法律问题，其他持“捍卫生命”立场的议员和法律思想家认为这根本不是什么十拿九稳的事。但策略家们目前正在抛出各种各样的想法，没人知道哪些法律能在法庭上站得住脚。
And in the coming months and years, we're going to be seeing all kinds of state laws using all kinds of tactics like these to try to crack down on abortion. I was interested to talk to somebody in the movement who is sorting through those ideas, trying to figure out what might work best right down, to hear how they're weighing the pros and cons of various approaches. And I went to one of the most forward looking, John Seago, President of Texas Right to Life.
在未来的几个月和几年里，我们将看到各种各样的州法律，利用各种各样的策略来试图打击堕胎。我很有兴趣和运动中正在梳理这些想法的人谈谈，试图搞清楚什么可能最有效，听听他们如何权衡各种方法的利弊。我去了最有远见的人之一那里，约翰·西戈，德克萨斯州“捍卫生命”组织主席。
Last year, Texas jumped to the front of the legal battle over abortion in our country when it passed the so-called Heartbeat Act, SB 8. That's the law that said that anyone in Texas, any private individual, could sue anybody who performs an abortion or anybody who even just helps someone get an abortion starting around six weeks after gestation.
去年，德克萨斯州通过了所谓的“心跳法案”，即SB 8，在全美的堕胎法律战中走到了前列。该法律规定，任何德克萨斯州的个人都可以起诉任何实施堕胎或任何甚至帮助他人堕胎的人，从怀孕六周后开始。
Seago helped shepherd that bill to passage. It's been widely imitated across the country. Seago's been talking to legislators and thinking a lot about what they should do next. And, for starters, he's somebody who does not think they should try to stop women from crossing state lines to get abortions.
西戈协助推进该法案通过。它在全国范围内被广泛模仿。西戈一直在与立法者交流，深思他们下一步该做什么。首先，他本人并不认为他们应该尝试阻止女性跨州堕胎。
I'm not confident that's actually going to work as far as legislation. You can't outlaw aiding and abetting an activity in another state, and I'm sure that there is language out there that may be offered this session to get around some of that, but at this moment, I don't think that that's going to be the best use of our efforts right now.
我不确定在立法方面那真的行得通。你不能取缔在另一个州帮助或教唆的行为，我相信本届议会可能会提出一些试图绕过这些的措辞，但在目前这个时刻，我不认为那是我们现在努力的最佳方向。
Are you saying that you think, actually, just from a practical point of view, it might be that the movement might have to live with the fact that some women are going to cross state lines, and there might be nothing that a state can do to stop that?
你是说，从实际角度看，这场运动可能不得不接受这样一个事实：一些女性会跨州堕胎，而且州政府可能对此无能为力？
I mean, this is a reality of federalism, and I don't think that that's going to be the best use of our efforts right now.
我的意思是，这是联邦制的现实，我不认为那是我们现在努力的最佳方向。
That means, Seago says, not going after somebody who crosses state lines for an abortion, or people, or organizations who help them do it, or advertising that lets people know about abortion clinics in other states. Instead, John Seago says the movement in his state, Texas, should be focusing on making Texas a more hospitable place to keep and raise a baby with more support for mothers.
西戈说，这意味着不去追究跨州堕胎的人，也不去追究那些帮助她们的人或组织，或者禁止宣传其他州的堕胎诊所。相反，约翰·西戈说，他所在州的运动应该专注于让德克萨斯州成为一个更适合生育和抚养婴儿的地方，为母亲提供更多支持。
This is something I heard from other pro-life politicians around the country. Seago says another thing they have to do now that abortion is banned in so many states, they have to make sure the bans are enforced.
这是我从全国各地的其他“捍卫生命”政治家那里听到的。西戈说，既然堕胎在这么多州被禁止，他们现在还必须做的另一件事是确保禁令得到执行。
The movement is unified that we need to fully enforce our laws. We have serious problems with that here in Texas with district attorneys saying they don't want to enforce our laws, even now with Roe v. Wade being overturned.
这场运动的统一目标是我们需要全面执行我们的法律。在德克萨斯州，我们遇到了严重的问题，地方检察官说他们不想执行法律，即使现在罗诉韦德案已经被推翻。
What he's talking about is district attorneys in Texas counties that contain Dallas, and Austin, and San Antonio, and Corpus Christi, also Fort Bend County on the outskirts of Houston. All these district attorneys joining over 80 prosecutors around the country in saying they will not prosecute doctors who continue to do abortions.
他指的是德克萨斯州包含达拉斯、奥斯汀、圣安东尼奥和科珀斯克里斯蒂等县的地区检察官，以及休斯顿郊外的本德堡县。所有这些地区检察官与全国80多位检察官联合起来，表示他们不会起诉继续进行堕胎的医生。
And so that's kind of one of the hurdles of how do we look at actually prosecuting that. Well, there's a couple of different public policy responses.
所以，这就是如何实际起诉他们的障碍之一。嗯，有几种不同的公共政策应对措施。
For instance, they could authorize the Texas Attorney General to prosecute those cases or have DAs from nearby counties do it. But the best solution, Seago thinks, is to beef up what they did in the Texas abortion law and give private citizens more power to sue any doctor who they think is still performing abortions.
例如，他们可以授权德克萨斯州总检察长起诉这些案件，或者让邻近县的检察官去做。但西戈认为，最好的解决办法是加强他们在德克萨斯州堕胎法中做的事情，给予私人公民更多的权力，起诉任何他们认为仍在实施堕胎的医生。
This, by the way, is also the approach recommended by the National Right to Life Committee. That's the national group that Texas Right to Life is affiliated with. They've drafted model legislation for states to adopt that would make it possible to prosecute anybody helping someone get an abortion in a state that's banned it by authorizing attorneys general to prosecute if local district attorneys don't want to do it and by giving citizens the power to sue anybody they think is breaking the law.
顺便说一下，这也是全国“捍卫生命”委员会推荐的方法。那是与德克萨斯州“捍卫生命”组织相关的全国性团体。他们起草了示范立法供各州采用，如果地方检察官不想起诉，就授权总检察长起诉，并通过给予公民权力起诉任何他们认为违法的人，来起诉在堕胎禁令州帮助他人堕胎的人。
Specifically, the draft legislation would give the father and the grandparents of the unborn child the ability to sue for compensatory and punitive damages if there's an illegal abortion. And if the pregnancy was caused by rape or incest, the father of the unborn child would not be able to sue for damages, but the way the draft law is written, his parents could.
具体来说，该法案草案将给予未出生孩子的父亲和祖父母在非法堕胎的情况下起诉损害赔偿的能力。如果怀孕是由强奸或乱伦造成的，未出生孩子的父亲将无法起诉要求赔偿，但按照草案的写法，他的父母可以。
So the other big thing I wanted to talk to you about is pills. This is the other way that it seems like women in states that have banned abortion might still be able to get abortions. Right now, more than half of all the abortions in the United States are induced by pills.
所以我想和你谈的另一件大事是药丸。这是女性在禁止堕胎的州可能仍然能够堕胎的另一种方式。目前，美国超过一半的堕胎是由药丸诱导的。
The FDA has approved these medications for use up to 10 weeks of pregnancy, and the states that have banned surgical abortions have also made it illegal for a woman to go online and just order these pills from a website. But as a practical matter, it seems very hard to enforce.
FDA已批准这些药物用于怀孕10周以内的使用，禁止手术流产的州也规定女性在网上订购这些药丸是违法的。但实际上，这似乎很难执行。
These websites are often overseas. It would just be very difficult for a state like Texas or any other state to kind of reach overseas and do anything to the people who set up those websites. What can be done there? Where do you see opportunities for state legislators? Where do you see the limits of it?
这些网站通常在海外。德克萨斯州或任何其他州很难伸手到海外，对那些建立网站的人做任何事情。那里能做什么？你在州议员身上看到了什么机会？你认为它的局限性在哪里？
Yeah, I mean, this is another question of enforcement. So that activity of mailing abortion-inducing drugs is illegal in Texas, and so we're definitely looking at how can we enforce the law, where we're looking to tools that are not typically used.
嗯，我的意思是，这是另一个执法问题。邮寄堕胎药的行为在德克萨斯州是非法的，所以我们肯定在研究如何执行法律，我们正在寻找那些通常不会使用的工具。
And so how is this getting to Texans? Well, it's getting to them through the internet. It's getting through their internet providers or through their cell phone providers. And so are they breaking any federal laws? Are they breaking any state laws?
那么它是怎么传到德克萨斯人手中的呢？嗯，它是通过互联网传给他们的。它是通过他们的互联网供应商或手机供应商传进来的。那么他们违反了任何联邦法律吗？他们违反了任何州法律吗？
But he says they're still figuring all this out. It's really not clear what's going to work. One promising option, he says, is to give the Texas Attorney General more power to prosecute companies overseas that are sending these abortion pills into Texas and to make it possible for private citizens to sue them as well, which, he hopes, will drag those companies into court in Texas to slow them down or stop them.
但他表示他们还在研究这一切。真的不清楚什么会奏效。他说，一个有前途的选择是赋予德克萨斯州总检察长更大的权力，去起诉向德克萨斯州发送堕胎药的海外公司，并允许私人公民起诉他们，他希望这将把这些公司拖进德克萨斯州的法庭，以减缓或停止他们的行为。
I know it's always been a bright line for everybody trying to stop abortion in this country that they don't want to punish a pregnant woman who gets an abortion or wants an abortion. But when it comes to these websites, it seems like, really, that's the person who's choosing to make the abortion happen more than anybody else. Do you hear talk of anyone saying, well, let's stop the woman in some way from doing that or penalize the woman?
我知道，对于这个国家所有试图停止堕胎的人来说，不惩罚寻求堕胎或想要堕胎的孕妇一直是一条红线。但当涉及到这些网站时，看起来真的，选择让堕胎发生的人比谁都多。你听到有人说，好吧，让我们以某种方式阻止女性这样做或惩罚她们吗？
Yes, I mean, there is a minority in the pro-life movement that they are focused on wanting to criminalize the woman seeking an abortion. That's a minority, but that is a loud minority, and, unfortunately, they're continuing to talk about that. We don't believe that that's the best priority for us. We don't think that that's really the best way that we can move forward.
是的，我是说，在“捍卫生命”运动中有一小部分人，他们专注于想要将寻求堕胎的女性定罪。这只是少数，但这是一个大声疾呼的少数，不幸的是，他们还在继续谈论这个。我们不认为那是我们的当务之急。我们不认为这是我们能向前迈进的最佳方式。
We think that, after 50 years of the messaging from the media, the messaging from, unfortunately, our highest court of the land that this is a constitutional right, and this is something that's necessary for her success. We don't think that it's just to immediately turn around and to criminalize this activity just because the woman has believed what the media and what the Supreme Court has told her for 50 years.
我们认为，经过媒体50年的宣传，不幸的是，我们国家最高法院50年来的宣传，即这是一项宪法权利，且这对她的成功是必要的。我们不认为仅仅因为女性相信媒体和最高法院告诉她的一切，就立即掉头去定罪这种行为是公正的。
So in the long run, Seago says that he wants to end abortion in every state. He says if you really believe that life begins at conception, you have an obligation to try to stop abortion everywhere.
所以从长远来看，西戈说他希望在每个州都结束堕胎。他说，如果你真的相信生命始于受孕，你就有义务尝试在任何地方停止堕胎。
But in the short run, in the next legislative session in Texas, his goal is to pass laws that will help enforce the abortion ban in their state and go after abortion pills and whoever is sending them into Texas, somehow.
但在短期内，在德克萨斯州的下一个立法会议上，他的目标是通过法律来帮助执行本州的堕胎禁令，并以某种方式打击堕胎药以及任何发送它的人。
I'm reporter Rebecca Grant, and this is Act 5, The Pill Smuggler.
我是记者丽贝卡·格兰特，这是第五幕，《药丸走私者》。
I think I seem like a little nice old lady. I walk my dog, and I'm a neighborhood kind of person.
我想我看起来像个可爱的小老太太。我遛狗，我是那种邻家大妈。
Do you think that you're able to do your legally risky work more safely because you come off as a nice little old lady?
你认为你因为外表像个可爱的小老太太，就能更安全地进行你这种有法律风险的工作吗？
Absolutely. Who else could do this but a nice little old lady that no one's going to pay any attention to? You know, who else can get away with this?
绝对是。除了一个没人会注意的可爱小老太太，还有谁能做这个？你知道，还有谁能逍遥法外？
This is Stephanie. Stephanie is in her 60s. She's a white lady, lives in a Southern red state, and what she's getting away with is this. She gets shipments of abortion pills from Mexico and India.
这是斯蒂芬妮。斯蒂芬妮60多岁，是个白人女士，住在南方一个红色州，她逍遥法外做的事就是这个。她从墨西哥和印度收到堕胎药的包裹。
Then she mails them out to people who can't get an abortion at a clinic. There's no prescription involved, no doctors or nurses. The people who get the packages will take the pills and do their abortion at home. The lingo for this is self-managed abortion.
然后她把它们邮寄给那些没法在诊所做堕胎的人。没有处方，没有医生或护士。收到包裹的人会自己服药，在家里完成堕胎。这方面的术语是“自助管理堕胎”。
Stephanie, by the way, is not her real name, and this is not her real voice. We had an actor copy what she said as closely as possible to protect her identity. Stephanie runs this underground operation out of her bedroom.
顺便说一下，斯蒂芬妮不是她的真名，这不是她的真实声音。我们找了一位演员尽可能忠实地模仿她的话，以保护她的身份。斯蒂芬妮在她的卧室里经营着这个地下业务。
When she gets a new shipment of pills, she puts on a pair of latex gloves, spreads out all her supplies on top of her king-size bed and divvies them up into little plastic baggies while she watches MSNBC. She loves Rachel Maddow.
当她收到一批新药时，她会戴上一副乳胶手套，把所有补给品摊在她的特大号床上，一边看着MSNBC新闻，一边把它们分装进小塑料袋里。她很喜欢雷切尔·马多。
So this is what it looks like. Sometimes it's a little bit thicker, and if you feel it, it's incredibly light, and I'll open it so you can see what's inside. Anyway, this is it.
所以这就是它的样子。有时它稍微厚一点，如果你摸它，它非常轻，我会打开它让你看看里面是什么。不管怎样，就是这个。
She showed me some of the pills.
她给我看了一些药丸。
So the big pill is our new exciting pill.
所以那个大药丸是我们新的令人兴奋的药丸。
In the last shipment, she received 50 mifepristone pills, miffys.
在上一次发货中，她收到了50片米非司酮。
And this is miso.
这是米索。
And over 1,000 misoprostol pills, misos. If all these pills were getting prescribed in a clinic, it would add up to about $30,000. She has generic versions. They're just as safe and effective.
还有1000多片米索前列醇。如果所有这些药丸都在诊所里开处方，总共价值约3万美元。她有通用版本。它们同样安全有效。
And miso is like a wonder drug. It's just considered exceptionally effective and very safe.
米索就像一种神奇的药物。它被认为异常有效且非常安全。
Stephanie has sent pills to hundreds of people. She fields requests through an encrypted email address. To send the pills, she stuffs them into bubble mailers from the dollar store along with a QR code that links to information about how to use them and the medical risks, which are few. Then, by hand, she writes out a random return address so that the package can never be traced back to her. She holds up a package to show me and my producer Aviva.
斯蒂芬妮已经给数百人寄过药了。她通过一个加密的电子邮件地址处理请求。为了寄送这些药，她把它们塞进一元店买的泡沫信封里，里面还放着一个二维码，链接到关于如何使用它们以及医疗风险的信息，医疗风险很少。然后，她手写一个随机的回邮地址，这样包裹就永远无法追踪到她。她举起一个包裹给我和我的制作人阿维娃看。
I usually go through houses for sale and put down an address of a house for sale somewhere in my area of the world.
我通常浏览待售房屋网站，写下我所在地区某个待售房屋的地址。
Are you just on Zillow or something?
你是在Zillow还是什么网站上？
Zillow.
Zillow。
How are you finding these houses?
你怎么找到这些房子的？
Yeah, mm-hmm, and then try to do different towns all over our area so it always comes from different towns.
是的，嗯，然后尝试在我们地区的不同城镇这样做，所以它总是来自不同的城镇。
Stephanie, to be clear, is not a medical professional, and she's definitely not supposed to be distributing medication, though she has no idea what the punishment would be if she got caught.
明确地说，斯蒂芬妮不是医疗专业人士，而且她绝对不应该分发药物，尽管她不知道如果被抓住会受到什么惩罚。
Is it a slap on the wrist? Is it a misdemeanor? Is it a felony? How bad is it? And there are no clear cut answers from the lawyers.
是轻判吗？是轻罪吗？是重罪吗？有多糟糕？律师们没有明确的答案。
Is that because nobody has been, in a meaningful way, prosecuted for that type of thing? So it's just sort of, like, untraveled territory?
那是因为没有人因为那种事情被真正起诉过吗？所以这只是某种尚未开发的领域？
I think so. Bringing miso across the border, is that legal or illegal? What if someone's bringing it in huge, huge quantities to provide all over the US? Do you think that will lead to prosecution, and the answer was, we haven't seen that yet. So until they start prosecuting people for it, it's all uncharted territory. No one really knows what risk they're taking, I don't think.
我想是这样。把米索带过境，是合法还是非法？如果有人带了大量、大量的货物供应全美？你认为那会导致起诉吗？答案是，我们还没见过。所以除非他们开始因为这个起诉人，否则全是未知领域。没人真正知道自己在冒什么险，我不认为。
Stephanie technically retired a few years ago, but she's one of those people who can't sit still. She describes herself as a doer. And so she started working with this nonprofit that helps people access abortions, and she felt relieved every time she could help a client MacGyver a way around the obstacles. But sometimes there are obstacles that couldn't be overcome, at least not without moving mountains.
斯蒂芬妮几年前技术上退休了，但她是那种坐不住的人。她称自己为实干家。所以她开始与一家帮助人们获取堕胎服务的非营利组织合作，每当她能帮客户想出绕过障碍的办法时，她就感到如释重负。但有时有些障碍是无法克服的，除非移山倒海。
And Stephanie realized that sending people pills to take it home was a solution. This way, they wouldn't have to come up with the money or figure out child care or travel hundreds of miles to a clinic. And, unlike the websites that sell these pills, they wouldn't need a credit card. It could really help people without an ID or a bank account or who were running out of time.
斯蒂芬妮意识到给人们寄药回家是一个解决办法。这样，她们就不必凑钱、找托儿所或开数百英里的车去诊所。而且，不像卖这些药的网站，她们不需要信用卡。这可以真正帮助那些没有身份证件或银行账户，或者时间紧迫的人。
So she decided to build out a shadow arm of her operation, all underground. When the nonprofit can't figure out another way to help someone, they give them Stephanie's encrypted email. There are actually people all over the country who do what Stephanie does, but no one really talks about it, even with each other.
所以她决定建立一个影子行动部门，全都在地下。当非营利组织想不出其他办法帮助别人时，他们就会给她们斯蒂芬妮的加密电子邮件。实际上全国各地都有像斯蒂芬妮这样的人，但没人真正谈论它，甚至互相之间也不谈。
It's very self-contained, like in the old days, the Soviet cells where you'd have the knowledge held by just a few. And I don't think I would ever be tortured for this information, but no one can tell how it's happening if no one knows.
它是非常自给自足的，就像过去苏联的细胞组织，知识只掌握在少数人手中。我不认为我会因为这个信息而遭受酷刑，但如果没人知道，没人能说它是怎么发生的。
Stephanie is obsessive about covering her tracks, but she can't control everything, like this one time at the post office. She goes there every day to pick up the above board mail for her nonprofit, all the bills, the donations, that kind of thing. But a couple of years ago, somebody sent a package of abortion pills there that was meant for the shadow side. Stephanie assumed no one at the post office would notice or care.
斯蒂芬妮对掩盖自己的踪迹非常执着，但她无法控制一切，比如那次在邮局的事。她每天都去那里领取她非营利组织的公开邮件，所有的账单、捐款之类的。但几年前，有人寄了一个堕胎药包裹到那里，是寄给“影子侧”的。斯蒂芬妮以为邮局的人不会注意到或不在乎。
They know me. They know my family. We all know everyone in the community. They let me know when I have packages. They text me or call me when I have a package. So one day, I was actually transporting a client from a clinic to their home, and I had just dropped them off. And I think I was in the parking lot just waiting for the next thing, and my phone rang, and it was the post office lady, who calls frequently.
他们认识我。他们认识我的家人。我们都在社区里认识大家。当我有包裹时，他们会让我知道。当我有包裹时，他们会发短信或打电话给我。所以有一天，我实际上正在运送一个客户从诊所回家，我刚把她们放下。我想我当时正在停车场等下一件事，我的电话响了，是邮局女士打来的，她经常打。
And I said, OK, hi, post office lady, what's up? And she said, I need to talk to you, I need you to come in right now. And I said, I can't come in town, and she's furious and just upset. And she said, do you know Jane? And I said, Jane? I don't know Jane.
我说，OK，你好，邮局女士，怎么了？她说，我得和你谈谈，我需要你现在过来。我说，我没法进城，她很愤怒，也很心烦。她说，你认识简吗？我说，简？我不认识简。
And she said, well, something was sent to your post office box in this person's name, and I opened it, and it has some illegal things in it. And I called the police, and they're here, and they want to open a case, and I want you to talk to them. So the police got on the speakerphone and said, do you know Jane? And I said, no, I have no idea who Jane is.
她说，好吧，有人以这个人的名字寄了一些东西到你的邮箱，我打开了它，里面有一些非法的东西。我叫了警察，他们在这儿，他们想立案，我想让你和他们谈谈。于是警察用扬声器说，你认识简吗？我说，不，我不知道简是谁。
Did you know who Jane was?
你知道简是谁吗？
Yes, of course I knew who Jane was.
是的，我当然知道简是谁。
And who was Jane?
简是谁？
Jane was one of my aliases.
简是我的化名之一。
Stephanie tried to stay calm on the phone, but inside, she was freaking out. She's not really sure why, but the case didn't end up going anywhere. Maybe it was because her name wasn't on the package. After that, Stephanie made sure she never got abortion pills at that post office, but she still gets all her legal, boring nonprofit mail there, and she knows the same clerk is going to handle it.
斯蒂芬妮试图在电话里保持冷静，但内心慌得要命。她不太确定原因，但案件最终没有下文。也许是因为包裹上没有她的名字。那之后，斯蒂芬妮确保她再也不会在那个邮局收到堕胎药，但她仍然在那里收到所有合法、无聊的非营利组织邮件，而且她知道是同一个职员在处理。
I take great pleasure about sending things to her that are labeled abortion.
我以寄给她的标有“堕胎”字样的东西为乐。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know. I guess it's petty, but I just want her, whatever her individual feelings are, to have to receive our abortion mail every day and hand it over to me. And every day, I go in there with a big smile on my face and say, I'm here to pick up my mail.
我不知道。我想这很琐碎，但我就是想让她，无论她个人的感受如何，每天都必须收到我们的堕胎邮件，并交给我。每天，我都带着大大的微笑走进那里说，我来取我的邮件了。
Stephanie knows that a crackdown on self-managed medication abortion is coming, and she worries that someone could try to prosecute her for aiding and abetting an abortion, even for being an accessory to murder. But Stephanie is hopeful that those kinds of laws will be difficult to actually enforce. There are just too many people sending too many pills in nondescript envelopes through the mail. It would be impossible to intercept every one.
斯蒂芬妮知道对自助管理堕胎药物的打击即将到来，她担心有人会试图以帮助和教唆堕胎，甚至是以谋杀从犯的罪名起诉她。但斯蒂芬妮希望那些法律很难真正执行。有太多人在普通信封里寄出太多的药丸了。要拦截每一封是不可能的。
There's no way to limit it. Yeah, no, it's available. It's widely available. If there's a need, there'll be a way to get it if people know where to go. We just need to get the word out.
没法限制它。是的，不，它是可用的。它是广泛可用的。如果有需求，如果人们知道去哪里，就会有办法得到它。我们只需要把消息传出去。
Stephanie is optimistic, but she still prepares for the worst. Every day, she wakes up early. She showers, does her hair and makeup, and gets dressed so she's presentable just in case the police show up to arrest her.
斯蒂芬妮很乐观，但她仍然为最坏的情况做准备。每天，她起得很早。她洗澡，做头发和化妆，打扮整齐，以便警察来逮捕她时她能体面点。
Coming up, scrambling to get ready for all the babies that are coming now that Roe is gone. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Pink House at the Center of the World. If you're just tuning in, we began today at the Mississippi clinic that was in the middle of the Supreme Court's decision overturning Roe versus Wade. And then, from there, we headed out to other places shaken by this seismic change in our country. So far, we have been to Illinois, Missouri, Texas, and in this part of our show, we now head back to the state we started.
接下来，罗诉韦德案既然没了，忙着为所有即将出生的婴儿做准备。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，稍后继续。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《世界中心的粉红小屋》。如果你刚调到这里，我们今天从那个处于最高法院推翻罗诉韦德案判决中间的密西西比诊所开始。然后，从那里，我们前往受我国这一剧烈变化影响的其他地方。到目前为止，我们已经去了伊利诺伊州、密苏里州、德克萨斯州，在节目的这一部分，我们现在回到我们开始的州。
I'm Emma Green. This is Act 6, The Babies. Babies are coming. No one knows exactly how many, thousands, tens of thousands. The pro-life movement has spent so long trying to get these babies here, to make abortion illegal, unthinkable, and now the movement has declared its next mission. They have to take care of these women. They have to take care of these babies.
我是艾玛·格林。这是第六幕，《婴儿们》。婴儿们要来了。没人知道到底会有多少，几千，几万。捍卫生命运动花了这么长时间试图把这些婴儿带到这里，使堕胎非法、不可想象，现在这场运动宣布了下一个使命。他们必须照顾这些女性。他们必须照顾这些婴儿。
In Mississippi, Anja Baker is the woman running point on all these babies. She's this super intense 27-year-old who's been fully dedicated to the pro-life movement since she was 15. Her dad's white. Her mom's Mexican-American. She's a Catholic convert.
在密西西比州，安雅·贝克是负责所有这些婴儿的人。她是这个超级强悍的27岁年轻人，从15岁起就完全致力于“捍卫生命”运动。她爸爸是白人，妈妈是墨西哥裔美国人。她是天主教皈依者。
On her left shoulder, she's got a tattoo of a giant white rose, a tribute to a German woman who resisted the Nazis. On the top of her right foot, she's got another tattoo of these tiny little footprints the size of a 22-week-old's, about the youngest age a baby can survive being born.
在她左肩上，她有一个巨大的白玫瑰纹身，向一位反抗纳粹的德国女性致敬。在她右脚背上，她有另一个纹身，是微小的婴儿脚印，大小相当于22周大婴儿的脚，大约是婴儿出生能存活的最小年龄。
And a lot of times it kind of freaks people out [LAUGHS] because that's not what they were expecting. And so when people are like oh, yeah, that's my tattoo, you know-- I remember talk-- run into a girl who was like, oh, yeah, I've got a tattoo in the same spot. And she was like, what are your tattoos about, and I basically was like, abortion and the Holocaust, and she was like, mine's a butterfly.
很多时候它会让人们有点害怕 [笑]，因为那不是他们所期望的。所以当人们说，哦，那是你的纹身，你知道——我记得谈到——遇到一个女孩，她说，哦，我也有个纹身在同样的地方。她问，你的纹身是关于什么的，我基本上说，堕胎和大屠杀，她说，我的是只蝴蝶。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I like butterflies.
我喜欢蝴蝶。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
So my tattoos have no chill, basically.
所以我的纹身基本上没有冷静可言。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I met up with Anja in Jackson. She took me on a tour of the post Roe world that she hopes to build.
我在杰克逊见了安雅。她带我参观了她希望建立的“罗诉韦德案”后的世界。
So, Anja, we'll meet you over there.
好的，安雅，我们那边见。
Anja works for a national pro-life group called Susan B. Anthony Pro-Life America. More than any other organization, they can take credit for this moment, for the careful political strategy that led to Roe falling. And now, they want to help all these babies, but they're not quite ready.
安雅为一家名为“苏珊·B·安东尼捍卫生命美国”的全国性捍卫生命组织工作。比起任何其他组织，他们可以把这个时刻归功于自己，归功于导致罗诉韦德案倒下的仔细政治战略。现在，他们想要帮助所有这些婴儿，但他们还没准备好。
For example, Anja's job is to create this online directory for Mississippi, a website of every kind of resource a new mom and baby might need, everything from diapers and formula to addiction treatment and housing help.
例如，安雅的工作是为密西西比州创建这个在线目录，一个包含新妈妈和婴儿可能需要的各种资源的网站，从尿布和配方奶粉到成瘾治疗和住房援助，应有尽有。
She doesn't include anyone, therapists, OB-GYNs, any organization who might help a woman get an abortion. I followed Anja around just four days before Roe got overturned, and her directory was still a draft. The goal eventually is to have a version of this in all 50 states. Right now, two are live.
她不包括任何人，治疗师、妇产科医生，任何可能帮助女性堕胎的组织。我在罗诉韦德案被推翻前四天跟踪安雅，她的目录仍然是个草稿。最终的目标是在所有50个州都有这个版本。目前，有两个是在线的。
I'm assuming he's in here. This is the resource center. Looks like they're sorting donations there.
我假设他在里面。这是资源中心。看起来他们正在那里分类捐赠品。
The first stop on our tour was a church that was stockpiling donated baby stuff.
我们行程的第一站是一座正在囤积捐赠婴儿用品的教堂。
We put crib mattresses up top. You can see the pack and plays there. There's two of those, and then the shelf right over, there's two strollers, I believe, and then there's some bed rails. And then over here--
我们把婴儿床垫放在上面。你可以看到那里的便携式游戏围栏。有两个，然后上面的架子上，我相信有两个婴儿车，然后还有一些床栏。然后在这一边——
Next, we visited these two pro-life activists in Jackson who brainstormed with Anja how to get more churches activated to join Anja's mission, to do more practical stuff to help women.
接下来，我们拜访了杰克逊的这两位“捍卫生命”活动人士，他们与安雅集思广益，如何动员更多教堂加入安雅的使命，做更多实用的事情来帮助女性。
As an African American woman--
作为一名非裔美国女性——
One of them, Monica, mentioned she's one of the few Black women who protests outside the Pink House, the abortion clinic in Jackson.
其中一位，莫妮卡，提到她是杰克逊粉红小屋诊所外抗议的少数黑人女性之一。
--just feel like I'm chosen.
——只是觉得我是被选中的。
Anja's excited to talk to Monica, in part because she wants the pro-life movement to reach more Black women.
安雅很高兴与莫妮卡交谈，部分原因是因为她希望“捍卫生命”运动接触到更多的黑人女性。
Do you envision this at Black churches, like, predominantly Black, not just the diverse churches? And if you do, how do you-- is anyone coming to mind? Are you getting ideas?
你设想这个在黑人教堂里，比如以黑人为主的，不仅仅是多元化的教堂吗？如果你这样做，你怎么——有人想到吗？你有主意了吗？
I am. I am over here like--
是的。我在这里像是——
Anja is a fix-it kind of gal, and, to her, the task ahead seemed straightforward. There were 3,559 abortions in Mississippi in 2020. She interprets this like a lot of other pro-lifers do, that the only reason these abortions happened was because women felt powerless, like they had no other option.
安雅是个修补能手，对她来说，前方的任务看起来很简单。2020年密西西比州有3559次堕胎。她像许多其他捍卫生命者一样解释这一点，即这些堕胎发生的唯一原因是女性感到无能为力，觉得她们没有其他选择。
So often, a different decision would be made that felt more empowering to her if she had information, resources, knowledge, emotional support. And I think, OK, there's an equation here. There's a woman who didn't expect to be pregnant but technically does want to stay pregnant, but this is missing.
通常，如果她有信息、资源、知识、情感支持，她会做出一个她觉得更赋权的不同决定。我想，OK，这里有一个等式。有一个女性没想到会怀孕，但从技术上讲想继续怀孕，但这里缺少了这个。
This, meaning some practical resource.
这个，指的是某种实用的资源。
Which could equal life. And so I thought, OK, so I can help with that gap.
这可能等于生命。所以我心想，OK，我可以帮助解决那个差距。
Did you ever spend time thinking about the other scenario, which is the woman who doesn't technically want to stay pregnant?
你有没有花时间考虑另一种情况，即从技术上讲不想继续怀孕的女性？
Yeah, but I find so often with the women who did not want to be pregnant, a lot of times it still comes down to an idea that she has about what it means for her, that she will lose her scholarship, that she will lose her job, that she will not be able to ask for leave, that she will be kicked out of her parents' house. Fill in the blank. A lot of the time, it's still that even if the idea of pregnancy doesn't excite her or wasn't something she was really looking forward to anytime soon.
是的，但我发现很多不想怀孕的女性，很多时候它仍然归结为她关于这对她意味着什么的想法，她会失去奖学金，她会失去工作，她将无法请假，她会被赶出父母家。填空吧。很多时候，即使怀孕的想法并不让她兴奋，也不是她近期期待的某种东西，它仍然是那样。
Anja is the kind of person who is looking forward to having kids. But even then, the reality of it has been complicated. She's a youngish mom with two sons, a toddler and a 14-month-old with special needs.
安雅是那种期待有孩子的人。但即便如此，现实的情况很复杂。她是个年轻的妈妈，有两个儿子，一个学步的孩子和一个有特殊需求的14个月大的孩子。
Her younger son Herschel needs to be nursed every four hours and can't sit up on his own. So any time Anja has to travel for work, like today, she needs to bring along a whole entourage of caretakers. Over the course of the day, we meet a baby sitter, Katie, Anja's mom, Cecilia, and her husband Nate, who holds Herschey and pats him on the back as we head from one meeting to the next.
她的小儿子赫歇尔每四小时需要护理，不能自己坐起来。所以安雅每次需要出差工作，像今天一样，她需要带上一整支看护团队。这一天里，我们见到了保姆凯蒂、安雅的妈妈塞西莉亚，还有她的丈夫内特，他抱着赫歇尔，轻轻拍着他的背，我们从一个会议赶往下一个。
We got the support team here.
我们有支持团队在这里。
She comes after 2:00. He does rocking when it gets out of hand. I do the nursing.
她2点后过来。他摇晃时失控了。我负责护理。
Medicine prep.
药物准备。
Medicine prep, yeah. We did the medicine early this morning. Yeah. Yeah, OK. Well, let's go.
药物准备，是的。我们今天早上早些时候做了药物准备。是的。是的，好的。那么，我们走吧。
Nate follows in his white Jetta with Herschey as we drive an hour and a half out to Meridian, Mississippi to a place called the Center for Pregnancy Choices.
内特开着他的白色捷达载着赫歇尔，我们驱车一个半小时前往密西西比州梅里迪安市一个叫“怀孕选择中心”的地方。
Hello, precious folks.
你好，珍贵的朋友们。
It's a pregnancy help center, or what's often called a crisis pregnancy center, these places where women can get ultrasounds and diapers and moral support. The pro-life world has had these for decades, in part to try and convince women not to have abortions.
这是一个怀孕帮助中心，或者通常被称为危机怀孕中心，这些地方女性可以进行超声波检查，获得尿布和道德支持。捍卫生命界几十年来一直有这些中心，部分是为了试图说服女性不要堕胎。
These are places where Jesus looms large. It's not like they're government agencies. But lately, state legislatures like the one in Mississippi are doling out millions of dollars to these centers. This is the safety net they're imagining for women who are pregnant.
这些地方是耶稣占据重要地位的地方。它们不像政府机构。但最近，像密西西比州这样的州立法机构正在给这些中心发放数百万美元。这就是他们为怀孕女性想象的安全网。
So there's a poster in the bathroom that says, are you safe at home? Has anyone in your home ever used words or actions to make you feel unsafe? Do you have--
浴室里有张海报写着，你在家安全吗？你家里有人用言语或行为让你感到不安全吗？你有——
A bubbly white woman named Sara shows us closets full of baby gear and flyers for women interested in getting their GED, and she takes us down the hall to a room with a blue sofa where women can come and talk about what they're dealing with.
一位活泼的白人女性莎拉带我们参观了堆满婴儿用品的壁橱，还有为对获得GED感兴趣的女性准备的传单，她带我们走下走廊，进入一个有蓝色沙发的房间，女性可以在那里来谈谈她们正在处理的事情。
So this is that safe space I was telling you about, and these are Preggie Pops. So if you decide to eat a candy, it'll help you with nausea.
所以这就是我告诉你的安全空间，这些是孕吐糖。所以如果你决定吃一颗糖，它会帮你缓解恶心。
Visiting all of these places, it struck me how big this task will be, how big the need is. The women giving birth in Mississippi tend to be poor. The state is the worst in the country when it comes to infant mortality and child poverty. Anja is not daunted by this. We talked about it in the car.
参观所有这些地方，我受到震惊的是这项任务会有多大，需求有多大。在密西西比州分娩的女性往往很穷。该州在婴儿死亡率和儿童贫困方面是全国最差的。安雅并没有被这一点吓倒。我们在车里谈过这件事。
Do you ever feel like you're asking too much of women?
你有没有觉得你对女性要求太多了？
Explain.
解释一下。
Like, I guess a thing that I'm stuck on is it feels different to be like, this is hard, when it's something that you wanted versus something you didn't want.
比如，我困惑的一点是，觉得这很难，当你想要某种东西时与不想要某种东西时，感觉不同。
Like, in the post Roe world, there are going to be women who are having babies who, before, would have chosen abortion and going through all of those really hard things also. And it just-- I don't know, it feels like it adds this layer that is just so heart wrenching. And I guess I wonder what you would say to them.
比如，在罗诉韦德案后的世界里，会有女性生孩子，而在此之前，她们本会选择堕胎，并经历所有那些真正困难的事情。而且它——我不知道，它感觉增加了一层让人心碎的东西。我想知道你会对她们说什么。
I really think that that is how life is, whether it's a pregnancy or somebody you love cheating on you or losing a job or your parent dying early. These are all-- I could go on, but these are things that happen to you that are immeasurably hard, that if anybody could choose for it to not happen to them, they would.
我真的认为这就是生活，无论是怀孕还是你爱的人欺骗你，或者是失去工作，或者你的父母早逝。这些都是——我可以继续，但这些是发生在你身上无法衡量困难的事情，如果任何人可以选择不让它发生，他们会选的。
If they could time it differently, they would, but these are things that happen, and people do get pregnant. And once there is a pregnancy, there is a life. So that life cannot be justified to be ended, period.
如果他们可以选择不同的时间，他们会选的，但这些是发生的事情，而且人们确实会怀孕。一旦怀孕，就有一个生命。所以那个生命不能被证明是可以终结的，句号。
When Anja imagines this new world, the world after Roe, it seems so clear to her. The need will be met. People will rise to the occasion. With enough phone calls and texts and emails and volunteer hours, she can fix anything. The babies are coming, and they'll be ready.
当安雅想象这个新世界，罗诉韦德案之后的世界时，它对她来说似乎如此清晰。需求将得到满足。人们会挺身而出。有了足够的电话、短信、电子邮件和志愿者时间，她可以修复任何事情。婴儿们要来了，他们会准备好的。
Act 7, Back to Jackson. So we end our show today by returning to the clinic that was the plaintiff in the Supreme Court case that overturned Roe versus Wade, the Jackson Women's Health Organization in Mississippi. If you remember from the beginning of our show, the day of the Supreme Court decision, they were overwhelmed with phone calls, people hearing the news and wanting to schedule abortions.
第七幕，《回到杰克逊》。所以我们今天以回到那家诊所结束我们的节目，那是推翻罗诉韦德案最高法院案件的原告，密西西比州的杰克逊妇女健康组织。如果你还记得我们节目开始时的内容，最高法院判决的那天，他们被电话淹没了，人们听到消息并想要安排堕胎。
And at first, they were turning people away. But the way Mississippi law works, the ban on abortion in the state wouldn't begin for at least another 10 days, which meant they had at least 10 days when they'd still be open and could perform abortions. Maisie Crow picks up the story from there.
起初，他们拒绝了人们。但根据密西西比州法律的运作方式，该州的堕胎禁令至少还要10天后才能开始，这意味着他们至少还有10天时间可以继续营业并进行堕胎。梅西·克劳从那里继续讲述这个故事。
The day Roe was overturned, remember, Shannon, the director, was in New Mexico trying to open the new clinic, Pink House West, and her sister Nita was running things in Mississippi. Around 10:00 in the morning, they get on the phone with Shannon.
罗诉韦德案被推翻的那天，记住，导演香农在新墨西哥州试图开设新诊所，粉红小屋西部，而她的妹妹妮塔在密西西比州管理事务。上午10点左右，他们和香农通了电话。
Everybody here now.
大家都在这里。
I'm trying to talk fast because I've got to talk a million people.
我试着快点说，因为我得和一百万人通话。
Shannon tells them, we have a month of appointments booked right now. I want you to call every one of those patients who are scheduled and get them all to come in during the next 10 days.
香农告诉他们，我们现在预约了一个月的名额。我希望你们给所有预约了的患者打电话，让她们都在接下来的10天内过来。
Those are the ones that I want y'all to call.
那些就是我希望你们打电话的。
And tell them what?
然后告诉她们什么？
Tell them that the thing just went down and they're not going to be open that week.
告诉她们那件事刚发生，她们那周不会开放。
Maybe they couldn't make any new appointments, but they could honor the ones they had.
也许她们无法进行任何新的预约，但她们可以履行已经有的预约。
See if they come in tomorrow.
看看她们明天能不能来。
They're not going to be open. OK, OK. First week of July. OK. OK, we got it. OK, we fill it up.
她们不会开放的。好的，好的。7月第一周。好的。好的，我们明白了。好的，我们填满它。
Fill it on up.
填满它。
OK.
好的。
And call me back. [INAUDIBLE]
然后回电给我。[听不清]
They decide they'll stay open for extra hours, and they'll come in on days they're usually closed.
他们决定额外延长营业时间，并且在平时关门的日子也过来。
Can Molly and Stephanie come in, because they was off tomorrow? We gonna need help.
莫莉和斯蒂芬妮能过来吗，因为她们明天休息？我们需要帮助。
She said, can y'all come in tomorrow.
她说，你们明天能过来吗。
I'll come in.
我会过来的。
Molly said she'll come in.
莫莉说她会过来。
Jackson Women's Health, hold please.
杰克逊妇女健康中心，请稍候。
And then, everyone gets back on the phones, calls everyone with appointments on the books and asks, can you come in sooner? How about tomorrow? How about Sunday?
然后，每个人回到电话上，给所有预约的人打电话，问，你能早点来吗？明天怎么样？周日怎么样？
12 and 2?
12点和2点？
12 and 2.
12点和2点。
OK. So we got a whole day tomorrow.
好的。所以我们明天整天都有。
Basically.
基本上。
A whole day. Just keep going.
一整天。继续坚持。
Yeah.
是的。
By the end of the day, they'd rearranged more things, called in other doctors, and even found a way to start booking new patients again too.
到一天结束时，他们已经重新安排了更多事情，叫来了其他医生，甚至还找到了重新开始为新患者预约的方法。
This should be fun. Yeah. [LAUGHS]
这应该会很有趣。是的。[笑]
For the Pink House, which had for so long been uncloseable, this is what closing looks like, a fight.
对于这间长期以来无法关闭的粉红小屋来说，这就是关闭的样子，一场斗争。
When you check out, the receptionist is going to give you this slip of paper. It's your appointment reminder slip. It has your return date, return time--
当你结账时，接待员会给你这张纸条。这是你的预约提醒单。它有你的归期，归还时间——
For the rest of the day, patients are shown into treatment rooms as usual. A doctor does the counseling session the state mandates with patients who come in for an abortion.
剩下的时间里，患者像往常一样被带进治疗室。医生对那些来堕胎的患者进行州政府强制要求的咨询。
Morning, ladies.
早上好，女士们。
Morning.
早上好。
Glad you guys got in here OK. I know you guys are here for an abortion. The state wants me to scare you guys and tell you there's a risk of breast cancer related to abortion. There isn't. So now I've told you. You can forget it.
很高兴你们过来了。我知道你们是来堕胎的。政府想让我吓唬你们，告诉你们有与堕胎相关的乳腺癌风险。根本没有。所以我现在告诉你们了。你可以忘了它。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So there's a 24-hour law in Mississippi in terms of waiting. I can't offer you anything today. I guess you're aware the Supreme Court overturned Roe versus Wade. So this clinic will be closing down very shortly.
所以密西西比州关于等待有24小时法律。我今天没法提供任何东西。我想你们知道最高法院推翻了罗诉韦德案。所以这家诊所很快就会关闭。
I can take care of you guys tomorrow. So if you're having the pill treatment, do not waste any time. Come back tomorrow, OK? If you need surgery, check with the front desk. They'll tell you what your options are, OK? Any questions, ladies?
我可以明天照顾你们。所以如果你接受药丸治疗，不要浪费任何时间。明天再来，好吗？如果你需要手术，向接待处核实。她们会告诉你们有什么选择，好吗？有问题吗，女士们？
Nikki Lane singing a cover of "When My Morning Comes Around," which she recorded for us. Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and Alix Spiegel and edited by Laura Starecheski.
妮基·莱恩翻唱了《当我的早晨到来时》，那是她为我们录制的。我们今天的节目由佐伊·查斯和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作，劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑。
The people who put together today's show include Jane Ackerman, Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea López-Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Kyla Jones, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Jessica Suriano, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
今天制作节目的人包括简·阿克曼、艾尔娜·贝克、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、安德烈亚·洛佩兹-克鲁扎多、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、凯拉·琼斯、塞思·林德、托宾·洛、米奇·米克、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、杰西卡·苏里亚诺、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sara Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Movie legend Carol Kane agreed to be the voice of our pill smuggler in Act 5 today. Maisie Crow's movie about abortion in Mississippi, which follows the Pink House and Shannon Brewer, is called Jackson. You can find it on HBO Max.
我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。电影传奇人物卡罗尔·凯恩同意在今天第五幕中担任我们的药丸走私者配音。梅西·克劳关于密西西比州堕胎问题的电影，跟随粉红小屋和香农·布鲁尔的脚步，名叫《杰克逊》。你可以在HBO Max上找到它。
Special thanks today to Mary Ziegler, Rebecca Curry, Andy Gipson, Clarke Forsythe, Elizabeth Nash, Diane Derzis, Javonne Brewer, Anna Wolfe, Larrison Campbell, Julie Lynn, Colleen McNichols, LaQuetta Cooper, Kawanna Shanon, Kelefa Sanneh, Jason Rosenbaum, Priska Neely, Mallory Carroll, Elisa Wells, Jill E. Adams, Pam Whitehead, Chloee Weiner, the National Abortion Federation Hotline, and Will Davis.
今天特别感谢玛丽·齐格勒、丽贝卡·库里、安迪·吉普森、克拉克·福赛斯、伊丽莎白·纳什、黛安·德齐斯、贾冯·布鲁尔、安娜·沃尔夫、拉里森·坎贝尔、朱莉·林、科琳·麦克尼科尔斯、拉奎塔·库珀、卡瓦娜·香农、凯莱法·桑内、杰森·罗森鲍姆、普里斯卡·尼利、马洛里·卡罗尔、伊丽莎·威尔斯、吉尔·E·亚当斯、帕姆·怀特黑德、克洛伊·韦纳、全国堕胎联合会热线和威尔·戴维斯。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org where you can find a link to the full Nikki Lane song you're hearing right now. Also, you can stream our archive. We have over 750 episodes for absolutely free.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以找到你现在听到的整首妮基·莱恩歌曲的链接。此外，你可以流式传输我们的档案。我们有超过750集绝对免费。
There's videos, lists of favorite shows, tons of other stuff there too. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia.
那里还有视频、最喜爱节目列表、成堆的其他东西。再次说明，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, he has squirrels at his house, in his garden, front yard, doesn't like them. Gets kind of intense about it.
你知道，他家花园、前院有松鼠，他不喜欢它们。在这方面有点强硬。
Stay out of the fucking driveway!
离车道远点，该死的！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - NIKKI LANE, "WHEN MY MORNING COMES AROUND"]
[音乐 - 妮基·莱恩，《当我的早晨到来时》]